thank you all and good afternoon I hope
you all enjoy your lunch
and there's lots of people here so
please cram in a little bit to the back
and I hope to make this talk
entertaining enough so nobody fall
asleep so for those of you who don't
know prime c3 is a patient computation
package built on top of a piano which is
a tensor computation library and so just
a little bit of plug in for those of you
who don't know prime C free is written
in in Python and it has I we can see the
stay of the arc inference engine nuts
and a variational inference and it was
it is under active development and it
has a really awesome community and for
me personally if you ask me why do I
like to use prime C free instead of all
these other libraries out there on the
free to use I often think that prime C
free keep as a way that is really easy
to interact with different components of
your model and I hope today that from my
presentation you can get to see a little
bit about ok how can I get a livelihood
from different components and how can i
when I build a model how can I check
different parts of the model to make
sure that I'm doing things for correctly
so for me personally I've been a
developer for prime C free for the past
a year or so and currently I'm mostly
maintaining a community of the primes a
prime C free on this course and I highly
encourage you to check it out of the
discourse we not only discuss specific
problem of using prime c free but also
if you have for example in a journal
question about okay i have to have this
problem i have to set up how can i use
prime C how can I use patient scientist
in general you can post a question on a
discourse and usually I would try to
just do a quick reply of okay here are
some
previous discussion on this topic you
can check it out and hopefully to kick
up the discussion a little bit so I
actually I'm I'm from a psychology
background so I study psychology in my
undergrad and PhD and I always do this
frequency statistics so I actually teach
patients and this in myself by using
time see free and some of the haunting
question of my quest of learning to be a
patient
is is quite challenging and some of the
questions for example how to be sample
from the wide reading sample from
posterior and how can we do that and
most specifically I used to be always
kind of confuse of okay why do repairman
monetization works so for example a
famous case is okay you have normal T's
you have some samples from a normal
distributions and you can sample it
directly from a Gaussian with the
parameter of mu and Sigma or you can
sample from Gaussian with zero means and
one the Sigma is a one and then two
linear transformations so this is
famously known as Center on an Center
for monetization of your model and
sometimes one works better than the
other but why is that because we if we
say that okay this two-way keeps you the
same kind of model then why why would it
works that one ways works better with
the other and I think all these
questions can be a bit better understand
by know a little bit more of what
exactly is a likelihood functions so
today I will first kind of go through a
little bit of the basis of okay what is
a probability what is the probability
density or mass functions and what how
does it link to a likelihood functions
and then a bit more practical of okay if
I'm building these models in primacy
free how does the computer likelihood
and how can you extract the likelihood
of the model and of different components
so in our daily life of
data science or analyzing data we are
dealing with a specific thing called
random variables we might not defy it
mathematically all the times but
basically is it is an an American
measurement of some outcomes of a
probability experiment those value is
determined by chance so formally is is a
function that map's the outcome to the
unpredictable process to a numerical
quantity so this is all really muffy so
what does it actually means so my random
variable describes kind of a summary of
some process for example thinking of
flipping a coin three times and we can
observe head and tells each time we
flipped it so at the end of the of this
serie of of this specific experiment we
can have different outcomes for example
we see the first two pin has and then
the third one being the tail and if we
do a summary of the of what we observe
we say okay we observe the number of has
been two times but actually as you can
see here there are three different paths
we can get to this advance so a random
variable is this number of number of
heads we observe so free 2 or 1 or 0 but
the process is describing is some kinds
of random procedure or random
experiments and when we are dealing with
a random variable use Rivia we associate
with some kind of probability
distributions so a probability
distributions is specified the
probability that is value 4 into a given
intervals for example in this case if we
are growing two dice we can observe a
random variable takes the value between
2 and 12 and this random variable will
be the sum of the the face value of the
two two dice so the experiment itself is
rolling dice and it when you observe is
is different numbers that comes out in
the in the two dice
random variable is the summary the sum
of these two numbers so regardless of
how specifically these two dies the
number is what we care about is the sum
of the two and so this is an example of
discrete random variable and we also
deal with a random variable or in on
continues it can take a continuous
values and in this case maybe a point
value is not that much of tick not that
much of meaning anymore but what's more
important is the value of the given
interval so these are all cover on just
a quick introduction is from Wikipedia
and all this theory is based on formally
the define of some kind of mathematical
foundations of course I will not go into
detail of it today but there's this
recent blog post by micro-pitting Hall I
highly encourage you all to read it it
gives you some formal language of how
you can think of mappings what is
defined as a random variable and these
things and in practice we usually are
dealing with a really limit specific sub
class of distributions so for example
here's our two two different cases and
they mostly are coming from for example
exponential family for example Gaussian
or pro song which gives us very nice
properties so okay let's thing of a more
specific case still a coin flip examples
so we are not talking about patient if
he's not flipping a coin
so say now okay a let's flip a coin four
five times and observe free outcome is
head and here the random variables would
be the number of heads that it observed
of course you can divide differently say
okay you can say it's a number of tails
that's also a random variable but the
underlying kind of physical experiment
that is summarizing is still the same
and also it comes also with some
specific kind of presets of the
experiment for example actually you can
get two different settings for example
first setting is that you flip to a
total number of five times and then
record output and usually it associate
with a binomial distribution that
describe all the probability of
observing different number of heads or
you can have a different setting that
okay I actually flip the coins until I
observe free comes out as heads and now
it will it can be summarized as
different a different distribution as a
negative by nominal so again the
underlying physical random experiments
do the same but the random variable in
in these two case are actually different
so okay let's say that we stick with the
first settings
amia telling me for binomial
distributions and usually you see that
is written as such but you can also I
actually encourage you to think of it a
different ways that it takes a three
different possible in input to these
functions and gives you one output of
the functions so the following a slice
you can there will be some demos you can
check it out on on these notebooks right
so let's start with the probability mass
functions of a binomial distribution so
we usually we can import it from inside
pi and it gives us a really handy mass
functions of the distributions and
usually defining as such that okay
assume that we know the number of coin
flip and assume that we know the
underlying
by nominal rate what is the probability
of observing different outcomes so this
is a way to show you that the if you in
a kind of conventional way be enough
when we are thinking of a probability
distribution we have the latent or
unknown as the by nominal rate so and if
we handle very differently my apologies
I have a co so so this is to give you
some intuitions of okay if I change the
underlying binomial rate how does the
distribution will change and this is
come we normally know as a probability
distributions and as for likelihood we
now kind of change the thinking a little
bit instead of seeing how the the
outcome change by the different rate
parameters now the by nominal rate is
kind of like our unknown and we change
the switch observe a little bit so to
read this graph is that you see on
x-axis being the by nominal rate
parameters and it takes the value
between 0 and 1 and the probability and
and the y-axis defines the probability
but this is normally call likelihood
functions the reason of these
distinctions is is because it doesn't
integrate it to one so if you compute
the area underneath the curve it is not
integrate 1 so it doesn't come as a
probability density functions but
actually this --tx distinction might be
a little bit misleading as you can see
we are still using the same
probability functions from from Sify
here and sometimes I write a thing about
it as the likelihood function is the
function that the parameter is equal to
the density but you index by by changing
the the input to the function so what
what does this means so let's look at
again our form a probability
distributions for all our mass functions
actually we have two parameters if you
we are taking this conventional form
there are two parameters that are
unknown or it can varies if we are
observing some kind of random outcome
the first one is the number of total
coin flip in this in this case and the
second one is the latent variables of
the binomial by nominal rate of the coin
an interesting thing to note a kind of
like a minor technical detail is that
actually when we are talking about a
probability function or probability
distributions or for example binomial
distribution we are talking about
actually a family of binomial
distribution and only when we fix the
two parameters now it becomes a specific
function and now this is the interesting
part of okay what about the likelihood
in this in this under this context so
now we still have to kind of unknowns
and in this case we are changing the
after the outcome to see what is the the
likelihood looks like and this is still
alive hood functions but each of the
entry or each of the small cell in here
is a probability and what you will
observe is that kind of in in a bottom
there is it takes the value of zero it's
kind of impossible value because when
you're observed for example a number of
heads is 10 it's impossible that you
flip the coins less than 10 times and so
immediately it kind of gives its
constraint and it changed the surface of
the heart of how the likelihood
functions who looks like and also it
takes two parameters because we have two
kind of latent variable or unknowns but
it's all we are still dealing with kind
of the same side pipe functions if you
were using side PI here and we take the
if we keep the inputs two to it as okay
now since these two are unknown I just
varied randomly or I just lay out the
whole grid of all the possible values so
again this surface gives us more
informations of of what a lady who
really looks like and I encourage you
when you're thinking of likelihood you
should all imagine you're in this kind
of space that makes up by different but
by different inputs or different
coordinates and also interesting things
just to point out is that when if you
are looking at this space and we are
doing maximum likelihood estimation
actually we'll get the maximum
likelihood the edge here which in this
context will be okay the maximum
likelihood is that we fit the coin for
seven times and we observe the head
seven times so it is kind of like okay
sure this is still correct answer but
it's a little bit pointless because it
does it doesn't really capture the shape
of of the likelihood space and that's
also some sometimes of a reason that why
we're very discouraged of when you're
thinking of just one a point estimation
because it can always be misleading and
probably more naturally when we are
thinking of distribution our likelihood
functions that takes two inputs we think
of like a Gaussian likelihood which we
have unknown for example is the MU the
and the Sigma parameters and it actually
maps out to this kind of a
two-dimensional space that we have two
different unknowns that we want to find
out so just as a quick recap we are
using the same functions when we are
dealing with probability either
probability density functions or
likelihood functions and it might not be
really useful when we making a very
clear distinction between two because
the output we are dealing with is still
a probability and so okay now we have a
kind of the case okay we have one
observations of the this render mix but
what about if we have multiple
observations or repeat mesh measurements
or repeat experiments and it turns out
there are ways to combine probabilities
with all these formulas and as a
consequence is this two famous rules of
some rules and product rules which also
give us naturally the the based on
theorems so now let's take a specific
case still with the coin free imagine
that we have a new coin a coin flip
experiment which we just flip the coins
for 1 times but we will recall any
record outputs so the the random
variable is just head or tails or 0 and
once when in maps it to to a real number
but we actually repeat this experiment
six times and say that we have the by
nominal rate is point seven so by the
rules of combining different probability
the probability of observing this exact
sequence we can evaluate it as such and
at the end we have the the probability
of observing exactly this sequence and
as you can see we are just doing a
multiplications of each X
and at the end arrived at these answers
and we can also use the SyFy function of
a Bernoulli distribution and usually in
in our daily life you just we use a lot
likelihood because this is easier to
work with for computers and we avoid
lakhs of numerical problems when we are
computing it so in this case we can take
the log of the each of the the Maxima
the outputs or we can just use directly
the log probability and now we if we
define these likelihood functions of
observing the sequence by using a doing
kind of this lambda functions and we
evaluate of all the possible range of
values of the by nominal rate we get
this kind of functions so on the Left we
have the likelihood functions for of
observing exactly the sequence and on
the right is the log likelihood
functions so how about how do we get
these dysfunctions how do we get these
things with these shapes now let's take
to look at just the one experiment and
if we observe the coin being come
outcome is zeros we have this kind of
likelihood and quite naturally we can
see thing of it that okay if the
probability being zero or the the
binominal
or the coins or the the rate of the the
coin the true one being zero then of
course when you freebie disk up it comes
up with zero so we have one on the far
ends and interest linear decrease so it
means that if when you have point five
so the coin is fair then is half and
half in the same for the for the
occasion or when it comes up with one
and now when we are looking at this
sequence we can do an update of okay
when we have more observations we can
update the likelihood functions so again
we observe 0 in the first
Firmin Rob says zero again a second
experiment and by the rule of the
probability then we are just multiplied
in them so we get if we multiply the
first two we get the third one so that's
the likelihood function of observing
consecutively two zeros and we can
repeat this procedure so okay again we
observe zero so we update further we
observe zero again we update furthers so
on and so forth and which keep us this
kind of sequence of updating and by the
end we have this likelihood function
with this shape which defines four for
the four likelihood functions that
observing exactly this sequence and
against this function we take the by
nominal rate as the autopen on the
normal rate of the input on x-axis and
on the y-axis is probabilities and you
might already observe that if you are
familiar with by nominal probability
functions you see actually the tool has
exact exactly the same shape it's
because the by nominal trial is actually
a kind of a generalization of AB you
know the only experiments and in this
case it's just that since we don't in
the binomial trial we don't care about
the sequence of the head and Tails so
actually the the actual numbers here are
different so you can see in the bottom
is that the numbers are higher looking
at our y-axis the number higher than in
urban only likelihood but the shape is
still the same and now say that we are
repeating a binomial experiment with
this sequence we can now apply it the
same as as we previously see and just as
a reminder the operation we are doing
here is that we observe the first trial
of the experiment second Travis
experiment and then we combine the two
Beauty multiplications
and we just continuing this these
procedures so again the few things just
to as a note is that okay that's the
order of the sequence kind of dissing
matters and at the end of 30 strips so
now let's take an example of a Gaussian
likelihoods and here is the first two
trials and if by the same procedures we
are multiplying them and it gives us
this kind of updating of when we have
series of Gaussian observations so a few
things to note here is that when we are
talking about the likelihood of just one
observations actually gives no
information of the Sigma because of
course when you may have one output we
don't know what the Sigma would be so we
don't know how how what is the how
random equal worries but as soon as you
have two observation you can infer the
parameters or it gives these shapes of
how the Sigma will looks like so it has
this pics here at the end where it gives
us more information of okay how is the
the the other parameters who looks like
so what about priors because now we know
about likelihood and what about if we
want to incorporate priors so say that
we have to with specifics on priors for
the the mean and a standard deviation
for this Gaussian examples and when we
are thinking of the operations in these
two dimensions we actually broadcasting
this probability into two dimensions so
here you see the first one being a mean
parameter and the second ones being the
Sigma again the the AXI here is not very
meaningful so just try to ignore it and
when you combine the two
it gives us the first third shape so now
let's say that we have this prior and we
have not now our same observations and
we see that it changed the shapes a
little bit when we are doing these
updates and we can compare them with
what we are originally see and you see
that quite interesting ly only the first
one is kind of like giving it a lot of
informations and as soon as you have
more trials the prior information kind
of quickly wash out but it's not always
the case because because you can have
[Music]
very few informations of informing you
how the likelihood looks like and in
those case of course your prior becomes
much more important so now let's go to
time series and with some actual
examples so go back to the coin flip
examples with binominal trials but it's
a little bit kind of unconventional is
that let's say that we also don't know
about what is the total number of coin
flip and we just give it a uniform
between 0 and 25 and observation here is
7 and when you define these models you
can check what is the the inputs to the
likelihood of these models by checking
the test points so here the test point
is because we have two unknowns we have
the test point is also takes kind of you
need to specify the coordinate of these
two unknowns and you can also get the
likelihood of different components so we
have the components for the for the
model likelihood and we can also have
the sorry we have the likelihood
function for the model riding hood and
also for the component likelihood and
for this likelihood functions that we is
called lose point functions because it
takes a point or a dictionary as input
and here what I what I'm doing here
that I evaluate the the likelihood
functions for both for both the model
and hood and a component component Lila
hood so for here that you can see that
the component likelihood is kind of it
takes no limits of from from zero to
whatever numbers but when you're looking
at the model likelihood it has this
cutoff at 25 it means that the prior
information is kind of kicking in it
restrict how large this space can be so
it can only goes to 25 and how prime see
free use via no in this case is that
when you define a primacy model we grew
up this graph of these functions that it
takes all it takes some inputs and it
returns an output so formally speaking
in this example it takes a real number
and also integers and it out comes
another real numbers and it has two kind
of free random variables as we defined
it and these two three random variables
if you check just one of them it has to
kind of likelihood functions but don't
become don't be kind of confused between
the two because one is a kind of a
property of a distribution of the
distribution or the underlying
distribution and the other one called
log log PT which is a tensor that is
kind of like the actual things that
we're interested in so for example if
you're defining some random variable
that is a attend a size 10 I read
actually the log P is due if you don't
specific specifications geller but a lot
PT in this case is evaluated on this
size 10 re and then in prime c3 we
collect all the component likelihood and
then we do the sum to get kind of this
model likelihood so when you have
constraints from the
you have information from the prior here
is where it kicks in in the in the model
likelihood so let's just quickly go
through two examples the first one been
a general linear models and you can
trick it check it out in this notebooks
called a regression with a twist it's
kind of so the first way when you define
a requestion so with the data as this
when you first define every question we
usually model it as this
so we have the two unknown parameters
one both with a normal prior and with
the observations as also following a
Gaussian distribution so this is kind of
like a conventional way to define your
model but actually it's equivalent if
you define your model as such it just
internally what time c3 does is that if
you first collect the log-likelihood for
the first free parameter and then for
the second parameters and then for the
third or actual observe random variables
and the potential is like kind of like
calculating that the log p and then it
collects it in in the model log
likelihood and actually when we are
thinking of this in the light of space
you can talk all kinds of crazy stuff
with it for example you can do it with
like this is a lipid twist is that okay
instead of defining okay that my
observation is following normal Gaussian
distributions actually my observation
subtracting a linear prediction is
following a Gaussian with zero mean so
it's kind of like more to the frequency
stood a sense but of course this is not
really encourage you to to do it just to
give you a sense of if you are thinking
of space of a logical functions actually
these two are equivalent
but be careful is that actually the is
not equivalent equivalent if you do the
first case when we actually divide in
the free parameter of standard
deviations and then give it a Gaussian
of zero one Gaussian of likelihood it's
because actually when we are doing
things like this we implicitly changed
or actually explicitly change the volume
of the the likelihood space and we need
to account for the volume change in the
content formations so when we have
changed more mesh transformation it's
just a fine transformation just
switching it around the volume stays the
same and actually this is what's IP
defined when you have a scale a location
scale distributions and there's a more
information of a more complex example
with a news funnel that is deals with it
shows you that okay if you actually
account for the volume change you have
the two identical models and I'm running
out a bit running out of time so just
really quickly as the last example is
thinking of a mixture model likelihood
so a mixture model is really difficult
to fit because we have this problem of
label switching so for example if we
sample sometimes we see that the labels
switch back and forth here is a between
different trace and so how do we do with
these problems and usually there's two
ways so let's take a concrete example of
okay this is the observe of Sir tater
with a normal mixture distribution with
the mean being minus 1 and 2 and the way
pin point three and point seven and if
we kind of map how what likelihood space
looks like it looks something like this
so why do we see label switching is
because when as a sample when is try to
map out this whole space actually needs
to charm
between these two local mayor Maxima so
which means when they have difficulty
jumping from one to the other
you're a problem of exploring the space
properly and usually there's two ways
you cannot many different treatments for
this one of the most kind of the ones
that works the best it is all the
transformations and if you and I used to
be really confused okay the older
transformation kind of gives you the
order but what about if I just sorted
the variable because if I sorted the
rabble with no constraints then the
outcome is always one larger than the
other and if the the trait seems to be
fine but actually it's now is if you
look at the space of the likelihood
functions actually there's do this two
local Maxima which means as a sample
that trying to map this space if you
still have problems of exploring the
whole space and just as a comparison
what the change is that it kind of now
mirror the two space so when you're
looking the parameter after you do the
transformation of sort the two values is
kind of you you kind of thing out
there's no problem but actually there
still is from the sample point of view
because the sample is only kind of this
little torch that only sees a little
area in the parameter space so and as of
more formal treatment you should either
use the potential which gives it an
order or use the other transformations
and just quickly to show you is that now
it actually modified the space and you
have a different parameter that the
parameter space is different so as a
recap is that there are many ways to
write down your model and repair ematic
station is more or less always change
the the model likelihood so if you
evaluate a model likelihood with one
parameter ization than the other you
should expect the likelihood output
change because
otherwise there's no points of writing
down your model differently and so
here's a few pointer for example make
sure it's correct
good parameterization soup easy to
understand and I would just really
quickly skip through here just focusing
on the last point is that when we are
building models we are setting up some
kind of space so it comes into a concept
record in a space which you can see more
in this examples and also it's
interesting also to thing about
regularization because you are also
modified in space and how it lends to
patient computations and also this a
good way to check your model by loke
interest at the slice of your light
liquid function because now in a slice
you can plot it and here is one of the
recent discussion of how to use this
technique to check your models and
lastly just some thoughts that I
encourage you to to have a read
afterward and thank you very much for
your attention
[Applause]
let's thank our speaker and we have time
for two questions do you have questions
so hello I have a question like as a
piano is being discontinued what is
there well idea for a PI MC free to to
use that so to switch it to some
different system or use some legacy
version yes actually we have a recent
blog post on this so you can check it
out on a median basically the plan is
for prime c4 we'll be partnering with
tensorflow in terms of low probability
to build a new interface on top of
tensorflow
and for prime c free actually we are
still on is to developing and most
likely is that we will have some
resource to kind of take over the
maintenance of piano or we have kind of
a local part of the a note just to make
sure that it still continues to work and
the prime c free maybe in the year or
two we will have a stable release or
prime c free with fear knows that use
you can expect it to still works for a
couple of years thank you let's say that
you know speaker
[Applause]